so hello everybody i'm here with richard
roland
for those who are involved in the
symbolic world you have seen him around
you've heard him he's written articles
for uh the symbolic world blog he's
involved in
the community in different ways he's
also the co-host of the ammon soul
podcast now
is involved with father andrew in
different projects
i would say he's involved in this really
he's completely aligned with what we're
trying to do which is
try to help people understand uh
traditional thinking in a modern way
help them understand how we can
re-embody relive these stories
um and one of the exciting things that i
found is that i've had this like secret
dream
for many years which is to restore what
we call
the uh universal history uh the idea
that the ancient peoples had a common
history that they shared
that they kind of had different
perspectives on um and
that like in the middle ages everybody
was just part of this massive story
um and i've always had this dream of
kind of helping people understand why
it's important and why it matters
and i've discovered in richard really
like a
like a partner we were both texting away
at each other
amazed at you know how we're excited
about the same seemingly obscure things
but that are not at all obscure because
they really can help ground us in a
common narrative so
so richard is a philologist he studied
ancient languages
he's also very smart works in data
science but i'm looking really forward
to
to our discussion today so maybe richard
you can tell us a little bit about the
things you've done
around us and then we can dive right
into the subject
[Music]
this is jonathan pageau welcome to the
symbolic world
yeah so i have um as you mentioned i've
written a couple of articles for
symbolic world i have a couple more that
are in the pipe
uh but i just keep not you know
finishing them
but uh uh but i've written some things
there specifically on hagiography which
is a subject that's really important to
me
um as it's it's actually the main genre
of of literature in the middle ages like
far and away
there's more ideography than literally
anything else
and uh but it's not you know not a lot
of attention is paid to it
yeah um as you mentioned i'm a
philologist um
basically that means i study old words
and and old texts and old stories and
the languages that they're all written
in
and um i'm i'm a data scientist which as
i i mentioned earlier is sort of a
modern day soothsayer
um and so uh but
uh my my main deal is is kind of looking
at
at medieval stories um two things one is
looking at medieval stories and
uh seeing meaning there um and then the
other one is sort of
i have a i have now developed a kind of
sideline in
reminding other academics that the
middle ages was a christian
period which you would think
people would know this but i mean i once
had a
i want to have a conversation uh with
a uh a fairly well-known medievalist
about the holy grail and i was talking
to this person and you know making an
argument for kind of a liturgical
reading of
christian's uh grail story which one of
these days we're going to do a video
on um and uh
and you know he said to me something
like well you know aren't you reading a
lot into that i said well i mean
there is a host in it and he looked at
me
no lie looked at me and said what's a
host
[Laughter]
so uh so my my uh
my basic sideline and i'm kind of in
connection with this there was i was
going through a recent translation of
the pearl poem
which i write about in in a midweeping
there is joy which is a book that we
had that just came out we'll talk about
that later but uh
uh i was i was reading the a recent
translation of the pearl poem and the
uh the scholar who again is a very
well-known medievalist
she translated the word mass as feast
just sort of like generically feast so
like
completely took the mass out of the poem
amazing which which the poem is all
about the mass
so things like that so basically my
my uh my new thing is just reminding
people of the middle ages was a
uh was a was a christian period and that
there was a
sort of a narrative and original context
for all of that and
um that that should actually affect the
way we read these stories
exactly and i think that what we want to
do now
is part of helping people understand
you know one of the things that i the
middle ages act as a kind of
mythological substructure to the modern
world whether people want to or not
you know there is there even though
people are trying to kind of move away
from it
so much of our so much of our dark like
even the idea of that it's kind of went
into the dark place where we have these
dark stories and these fairy tales and
these strange
misunderstood uh stories you know
because the fairy tale even if it's not
medieval has
its medieval in its structure and it's
medieval in its uh
illusions let's say right so all of that
shows us that the middle ages are acting
as this kind of just like for the greeks
of the times of athens you know the
trojan war
and uh and and the uh the odyssey where
like this mythological
backdrop to what who they were the
middle ages are the mythological
backdrop to who we are who we are and so
we need to
diving back into it and having a clear
vision of
what it can tell us and how it can
structure our more consciously structure
our reality can
can be one of the solutions to the
disenchantment that we're facing
it's it's funny because um somebody
asked a question
and i'd this might have been on an
episode i think this is on an episode of
the m school podcast
somebody somebody wrote in with a
question of basically like well
why is all fantasy or like the vast
majority of fantasy why is it set in a
medieval setting
and it's it's for exactly the reason you
just described this is what i was trying
to explain it's that that's where we
look back to right that's where our
meaning comes from
even even that's where our monsters come
from uh that we're dealing with right
now like it's all
it's all sort of contained in there uh
because the
you know there's this big medieval
synthesis where basically
it's the only time in human history when
we we've really had
everything sort of come together and
mesh together and fit together
that's amazing because you say that and
everybody so many people who are
listening will think
what the dark ages had a synthesis where
everything came together
and it just shows how ignorant we are of
what the middle ages had
well and that's really you know you know
we're going to be talking about
universal history today
that's really what universal history is
about it's about it's about showing how
the the christianity of the middle ages
um
chesterton in in his poem the battle of
the white horse he said
it's only christian men who was it it's
only christian men who protect even
pagan things
in other words you know only
christianity you know has
has the let's say the
catholicity the universality right to to
actually take in
the entire pagan world and integrate it
find a place for everything
and that's what you see basically
happening in in universal history
it's a way of fitting
our story right the story of my people
whoever my people are
into kind of a master story a master
narrative
yeah and this is something which
was already was already there let's say
before
christianity that is we have to
understand that the ancient
pagans had a intuition about other
peoples which is that
when they would encounter other peoples
they would
they would always be trying to to
pinpoint
for example like okay so they have these
strange gods uh
let's recognize the strange gods right
so okay so when they talk about this god
they're referring to zeus so they're
referring to ares
but they're referring to different the
different the same gods we have
they just have different names and some
of them and it wasn't like a perfect
system sometimes it was like
well their god seems to be like
adjoining of these two gods that we are
that we're worshiping let's say but
there was a sense in which
it's not like the like this this strange
modern idea that somehow
uh things are so arbitrary that they
just pop up
and you people can have all these
traditions that are arbitrary but rather
that there is a common human experience
whether we're connected
historically or just in terms of our
nature that will
that will bring about similar stories
that will bring about similar
uh principalities that will notice
different principalities in the world
and we end up worshiping uh the same
gods and so
even it was there before christianity
but then when christianity arrived
there is almost this idea that all of
this now culminates into
into christ and all the good elements of
these ancient traditions
can be kind of pulled into this one
story
yeah um in the discarded image lewis
says i think it's in the preface or like
the introduction to the book he says
that there was of course of course and
he he actually divides it into right and
left
um obviously you'll understand and your
your
listeners have been paying attention for
a long time will understand the
symbolism of the left hand really is to
sort of push something away
right so he says there's a christian
left that was always trying to get rid
of these things
yeah but then there was always a
christian right who would say along with
you know saint justin martyr or justin
the philosopher
whatever true things have been said by
men at any time
belong to us christians of course you
could look at that now and say oh that's
just appropriation
appropriationism or something like that
and first of all
technically yes right there is you know
this
uh university in california that has
this proposed
you know uh class that they wanna they
wanna start teaching that that actually
christianity is guilty of what they call
theocide
which again yes sort of our deal
right but also but also
uh what what people don't always
understand there is that when these
things die
that they have a capacity to be
resurrected in a way that allows them to
participate within the larger story of
the christian world
so you do see the seeds of this
happening and i mean for instance
herodotus when he encounters egyptian
society spends a whole lot of time
trying to figure out how do the gods
that the egyptians worship
match up to the map to the gods that we
worship
right but then what christianity does is
it it integrates it in a more
complete way right so that you so that
you don't have competing principalities
so that everything
is able to to kind of lay itself out in
a hierarchy
that lets you figure out where your
story
fits into this larger narrative yeah
exactly
um and the idea that the idea that we're
appropriating it's so hilarious
it's as if it's it's like you think that
we were that these were copyrights or
that
the purpose of of the world is to be
original and to like
come up with the new thing that hasn't
been done before every time someone says
that christianity has elements of things
that are there before them i'm thinking
like are you are you are you patenting
these things like what reality what
reality do you actually live in like
that's how it works
we we take the things that are given to
us and then we
we try to fit them in a way that will be
more that way more real and that will be
more
um conducive to to uh like a universal
history like the one that christianity
finally ended up
coming towards you know that this was
actually a process a historical process
that wasn't done by one person that was
kind of we don't even know
who was doing it sometimes it just is
this organic thing that
that happens and pops up in legends and
pops up in different different texts
um but it's just a funny thing like to
think that somehow
like somehow these stories that again
once again that somehow reality is so
arbitrary
that that we could that we could be like
stealing ideas from other like
like companies steal tech ideas from
each other you know
yeah um one way to think about
the development of narrative in the
middle ages is that
it's not until a very very late stage
basically until dante right dante is
kind of the first self-conscious author
right in the sense that that he's really
the first person
i mean obviously there's a lot of there
are a lot of works which will begin with
you know oh pray for the poor rat [ __ ]
sinner whose name
i'm not even going to give you because
i'm so unworthy because i'm going to not
relate to you these great things or
something like that
um but dante's really the first the
first sort of like
uh in one sense kind of you know he's
standing right there on the cusp of the
the medieval and the modern because he's
the first person who sort of
writes himself into the story but before
before that uh the writing in the middle
ages is characterized by two things one
is a
deep respect for authority and authority
really
at the end of the day means anything
else written down right because writing
is very expensive people don't write
stuff unless it's important
um so a deep respect for the authority
of
the earlier text and then also secondly
basically no concept of the idea of
authorship like
our ideas today of authorship plagiarism
things like this
would not would not even make sense back
then that's why
when people get a little hung up on
things like
well you know who's who's the real
author of this
pseudo-a pigger full text like
only only a modern person can ask that
question and it'd be meaningful
right um you know uh so i wrote an
article on the
on the symbolism of saint dionysius
theriopogite
right and uh and his his story basically
just
takes all of everything i'm saying right
now and just kind of combined it right
so there's this this whole body of text
and the question is you know
most scholars today say it it was
actually authored by somebody that
they're going to call
pseudo-dianese dionysius you know so so
in other words not dionysius but
somebody else writing under his name
right well that's that's essentially
just a modern hang-up
um yeah and also the idea it's also
because it's the idea that texts
uh exist in a vacuum because the the
person who wrote that
pseudo diagnesius or whatever who knows
who who wrote it
didn't write it out of his just out of
his own mind he didn't just sit down and
think up something new to write
he was writing it based on things that
had been handed down to him
and and even if we don't know exactly
how these things were handed down
they reveal themselves as being as as
they're received by the church
and integrated into the church as
appropriately
transmitting certain things which were
already there in the in the in the
tradition
right yes all right so let's go let's go
let's go
into the to the to the history so when
we talk about
universal history uh the biggest thing
that happens
is the joining of the hellenistic
tradition and the the the christian or
the jewish
history or the hebrew history that seems
to be like the biggest thing
that happens and it happens in troy in
alexander
and and then ultimately joining all of
this together with like the
genealogy genealogies of scripture and
how these different uh
these different groups relate to each
other so if you can tell us a little bit
about
how what that looks like let's say so i
think kind of the first moment where
this happens
is actually probably in the book of
daniel
um so in the book of daniel you have
these prophecies
and of course whether or not you think
their prophecies
will depend on whether or not you
believe such a thing as prophecy is
possible you know
can people write about events before
they happen um
but in the book of daniel you have these
prophecies some of which concern
alexander the great
and so there's this legend that goes
back into
the time of antiquity that alexander the
great
shows up to jerusalem with an army
and the the the people of jerusalem come
out
and they uh you know they're
you know you know please spare us don't
destroy the city et cetera et cetera
and um and so they bring out
the the high priest brings out the book
of daniel
and he reads to alexander the
uh the prophecy concerning the rise of
the macedonian empire
in in the book of daniel and alexander
is so profoundly
impacted by this that he spares the city
you know so this is this is the
tradition and of course we know
historically that alexander whenever he
went
to a city he would always figure out
what does he need to do to join
that city's pantheon how does he become
adopted as a son
of the principality of that city right
and so we can
so i think i think you know you can you
can see that same pattern manifesting
itself here and in this case
it's not that alexander it's not that
alexander can
uh you know sort of ritually become you
know the
the heir of david or something like that
but
there's a there's a joining at that
point between what's happening in the
hellenic world
uh which is not a it's not a secular
thing right alexander's rise is not a
secular thing right he's
he's identifying himself as a divine
figure as
actually multiple divine figures you
know the whole
alexander story is deeply religious you
know to the point that
uh even long into the middle ages
right alexander is sort of seen as this
pre-christian
uh manifestation of the virtues like
sort of as like the highest
the highest human development that you
know the highest you could get without
actually being a christian
um and and uh i mean you've talked about
you know the ascent of alexander
and sort of he ascends and then sort of
hits his limit
he can't go any higher than that right
so
and there's there are some traditions
about alexander which have him
actually recognize the god of israel and
recognize the one god so he's so
impressed
by the priests that come to greet him
he's so impressed by what he sees
in terms of worship that he that he he
declares
the unity of god and that and this is
important people understand because that
legend
that's why alexander is in the quran
like alexander is in the quran because
there was a tradition
which was there within the christian
world that
alexander had recognized the unity of
god
and and therefore was acting like a
predecessor
to what christianity would be which is
the pagans
recognizing the god of of the hebrews as
being this one
this one god and there's something about
that
what's important is like there's
something about that which is legendary
but there's something about the fact
that alexander
was aristotle's student and there's a
whole tradition
of alexander exchanging letters with
aristotle and these are all apocryphal
or whatever but that
the fact that he was aristotle's student
that aristotle had that notion
of a single that that divinity was
one and that there was an unmovable
mover
makes the these legends that went around
it
not completely insane not completely
unfathomable right rather talking in
narrative form
about a reality which is slowly
developing
in the west which is this capacity to
see
the unity of the divine and and to start
to formulate it in a way
that would ultimately culminate in in
christianity
uh and so there is this sense in justin
martyr and in and in some of the early
fathers that
this seed was there in the the the
in the greek in the greek philosophers
that there was a seed of what
of what christianity would bring was
already there so these legends of
alexander are talking about that in
narrative form
and they end up creating something as
powerful
as having having alexander in a sacred
text
in the islamic sacred text so another
another
text tradition that is closely that is
closely related to this
um is in the is the is the sibling
oracles
which i've been reading through recently
i'm about maybe halfway through
um and those are we thank you for
reading those because they're
they can be tedious sometimes but
there's some real nuggets in there um
so just to say uh you know usually we
associate maybe
if you're a student of like mythology
and folklore you might associate the
sibyl with rome which is not incorrect
but actually in the ancient world they
were like a bunch of different sybils we
tell people what a sybil is because a
lot of people
will not know it a civil a sybil is a
it's a female oracle basically it's a
female
prophet a seer somebody who's been uh
given access by the divine to
to sort of know the know the future to
see the pattern manifesting itself in
reality and so actually
um your your video on the apocalypse uh
the beast of the apocalypse came at a
really good time because it came out
just as i was getting into the sibling
oracles
and something that's that's uh
really key in there is of course uh you
know scholars have gone through there
and they said well this verse sounds
like paganism so this this verse was
written by a pagan
but then this verse is clearly you know
supposed to mention you know
refers to to christ and so this this
verse had to have been written by a
christian
and then they come across a verse that
says well this verse references
vaguely judeo-christian moral values but
it doesn't explicitly mention christ so
that one must have been written by a jew
and they they dissect it like this you
know
man you know why i hate scholars so much
i know
i know i i apologize on behalf of my
tribe i really do
but uh but i mean like it can be a
little maddening to kind of
to kind of like try to trace that down
but if you if you just take all of that
source criticism and you just set it to
one side
and you read the whole thing it is
actually especially if you're familiar
with any other
ancient medieval literature deeply
cohesive
um and one of the things that's
interesting in there you said in
in your your video on the beast of
revelation
that uh prophecies
the way prophecies work you know they
don't they don't just refer to the one
event at a certain point in time
otherwise
once that event was passed nobody would
read them anymore right but rather
it's almost because there's this fractal
fractal uh structure
to reality that prophecies
you can see you know they deal with the
patterns and
even if the the accidents change the
patterns manifest themselves over and
over again
and you see that in the sibling oracle
so for instance when they're dealing
with judgment against a certain people
they'll pick two historical events
that we would know like
in a chronological sense happened 500
years apart
but they both happened to the same greek
city where they both happened to roam
right and so the sibling oracles uh
which
you know probably do come together as
sort of you know
probably a hodgepodge of different
sources because you know
even if you if you believe what the
ancients believed there are
many different sybils and they're
writing at different times and at some
point somebody could
you know collected these prophecies
together and of course the first and the
most important sybil you'll like this
is noah's daughter-in-law interesting
yeah so it all goes back to or
it all goes back to noah and in fact in
the first it's either the first or the
second sibling oracle there is this
passage
where it drops out of prophecy because
it's describing the flood
um it drops out of prophecy and it just
starts describing
here's what happened in the flood and
it's
this deeply realistic firsthand account
of
of noah opening the door of the ark and
what or the window of the ark and
looking out on the sea
and what he saw and how he felt and the
color his
face turned and you know just the you
know like all this stuff like it's
it's this deeply actually i mean it felt
like something
tolkien could have written about the
downfall of numenor in fact
some of the language was so close
that it made me like kind of raise an
eyebrow but then
you get to the end of that oracle and
the the the prophetess reveals herself
in a riddle
and if you work out the riddle it's
she's the daughter-in-law of noah you
know since she was
on the ark so
you could even the existence of these
symbols and the existence of
the the the kind of strange what you
could call mixture of
of the the some pay more pagan symbols
some more christian some more jewish and
how they're kind of brought together
right on the one hand you could say that
this is syncretic and it is
but out of that syncretism can be pulled
a notion
that whoever it is that pulled these
these uh
legends together thought that these were
could exist
together like that they were living in
the same world that somehow the
hellenistic world and the jewish world
uh
had a way to talk you know had ways to
talk to each other
um that's the thing whenever somebody
starts to say such an incessant credit
i'm always like
why is that an objection to you like
have you met people
you know like how else do we do things
yeah yeah it's and it's also about me
it's about meaning it's like
understanding that what makes what makes
syncretism
problematic is when it goes against the
the the truth right when it moves
against the truth
but when sometimes it points towards the
truth and so that's why
some of the the ancient myths have a
little seed of understanding what christ
will ultimately reveal
and in those seeds we can see something
valuable
um and for example like we all know that
every single culture in the world has a
flood narrative
so we could say something like oh those
stupid cultures they just copied the
jewish story and
and it's all the jewish story copy the
you know don't look at that
it's it's horrible or like you said or
that it's just
the jewish or you could see no there's a
definitely a common
ba the common experience on which this
is based
whether it's a common experience in
terms of of history or if it's an
actual almost like uh genetic or like
human nature thing that we have in us
that is that is
that bubbles up no matter what you do
that it's a it's almost like an
imprinted memory on the on human nature
it doesn't matter how you look at it
that means that you can get
nuggets from these other stories as well
and you can get a sense
like when you read gilgamesh there are
some things about about the ancient
uh flood that actually shine brighter
when you read the gilgamesh story
because you're like oh they're doing it
this way and so you say oh
so it's pointing to something that i had
noticed in the other text
yeah and maybe it's also worth kind of
pointing out here
um so the simply oracles are
they're they're sort of part prophecy
part history but
there's the two things are so interwoven
that you can't actually
uh separate them yeah and
part of part of being able to understand
the idea of a universal history is being
able to also understand it in terms of
apocalypse
and these two things always go together
i mean we've talked a lot about this
particular volume from the
dumbarton oaks medieval library which i
have a lot of on the shelf over here
um and uh so this this connects two
works
one is the apocalypse of pseudomethodius
and the other one is an
alexandrian world chronicle so the
apocalypse of pseudomethodius
is basically like um
dealing with the whole idea of
after the after the roman empire was
dealing with really it's really sort of
like dealing with the story of the rise
of islam
right so after the after the roman
empire has has come has christianized
has established peace why then are bad
things happening you know
didn't didn't we didn't we like you know
to put it in
in arthurian terms like didn't we find
the grail like shouldn't things be good
now like what's going on
um and then the alexandrian world
chronicle is uh is under their work from
roughly the same period
that is basically just a very
straightforward blow-by-blow universal
history of the world in fact
if you want an easy introduction to a to
a universal history
you could you could do a whole lot worse
than than the alexandrian world
chronicle
but uh the fact that these two things
were just included in the same volume is
a wonderful sort of symbolism happens
moment
because the two texts are not you know
related in that they're from the same
author
but they are of a piece right um that
ancient peoples understand you have to
understand history to understand
apocalypse and vice versa right because
the the history is here's the way that
the pattern manifested itself before us
you know this is where we're from this
is how we fit into the story
but then the apocalypse is that same
thing looking forward
yeah right and even uh okay so i grew up
in basically the same kind of culture
that you did right fundamentalists
baptist evangelical right um
and so you'll know that there's a deep
obsession
in that culture with the end times the
book of revelation etc
and of course one of the things now this
may not have been an issue for you
because you're from
you're from the land of canadia i think
um
i think that's how you guys say it
canadia the orlando i'm actually
not i'm from the land of quebec yeah
because tobacco oh you don't
identify with those okay yeah um
but in america uh in american
evangelical culture
there's a deep obsession with trying to
find the nation of america
in the book of revelation it's really
important
um that americans and like
i've got bad news for you if it's there
it's the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
he's like okay i don't i don't disagree
with you but it's
but it's like uh so so actually so a
good example of this would be
uh there's there's this moment when uh
the
the the virgin who bears the child you
know uh
is it tur the church or is it mary i
mean it's both it's
not hard people it's both yeah but
anyway um she's born up
on the wings of an eagle to a safe place
and so they will say
the wings of the eagle is the united
states air force
oh my goodness i have sat in stop like i
had a i was a i was a i mean part of my
story too is i was a baptist pastor
before i was
became orthodox and uh so i've sat in
theology classes teaching where they
were teaching eschatology and that's
what they said
in the class that the wings of the eagle
are the united states air force
carrying the chosen of people chosen
people of god to safety so see
there it is america is part of the story
now that's and you wonder why there's so
many atheists like you just wonder
so it's okay but it's wacky yes
but it's actually also a pretty
normal impulse yeah to try and find
where is what's your place in the
pattern like what you know
in the story that's being told and the
pattern that's manifesting like where do
my people fit in
yeah um and that's that's kind of what
you a universal history is about
and and part of the the loss that we've
had
as a result of the the loss of the
medieval model
the part of the loss that we felt has
been
uh not having a universal story that we
can plug ourselves into
and so that's actually been been
replaced we think we're so cosmic
cosmopolitan but it's actually been
replaced by much more parochial
narratives
yeah um like like the the sort of
uh you know evangelical american
conservative narrative
you know as america is the new israel or
or
lika even even things like the 1619
project i don't know yeah yeah yeah
their desire a desire to read
[Music]
those are ways of doing mythology but
they're not universal
they don't actually you know they're
actually ironically deeply
non-inclusive yeah and so the
the way that i kind of see it and i
think that you're pointing to the
apocalypse and to the
let's say legendary history um there's
something about
so if it just exp in terms of experience
so you can imagine you we have your
moment like the moment in which you live
and that moment is you what you you have
access to a certain granularity
to that moment if you want to right you
can kind of access
the the the details of this moment okay
but the more you go forward and the
further you go back in both directions
yes the more you move towards pattern
right and that just will happen normally
because in order for you to remember
things from a very long time ago
they have to synthesize into patterns
and in order for you to talk about
something that hasn't happened yet
but that is following that pattern then
you also have to use images
that are universal enough you know for
them to then find body
in the future uh and it's like if i said
something like
i'm gonna die right i'm gonna meet death
one day
it's like i'm talking in patterns i
don't know how i don't know but i i know
because i understand the pattern of life
that this is going to happen and so i'm
predicting it but i'm not saying
i'm not saying that i'm going to get
this disease or that i'm going to be
this age or you know so
as you move towards the future you talk
you move in patterns and so
that can help us understand why the
legendary history
both this the story in genesis why it's
so patterned
and why it looks like the end of
revelation with the with the heavenly
jerusalem
and and why the prophecies of ezekiel
are
talk about paradise and the mountain of
precious stones and
all this type of imagery because it's
it's it's both like
there is this extreme in the in the the
past and the future
of how you can actually see the pattern
uh more easily when you look at
at things that are very far away in in
both directions let's say
um and so in the universal universal
history that's something that happened
and so
uh one of the elements of the universal
history is trying to trace all people's
back to noah
right and the way that they would do it
was
almost like through ontology you know
through the characteristics of the
people
to a certain extent so there would be
like their place in the world
geographically but there would also be
like an understanding of the
characteristics of the people
so a good example that i like to use
which is which seems arbitrary is that
the hungarians
see themselves as descendants of nimrod
and you think like how could you ever
prove that you can't prove anything like
that like this is obviously not
but there's something about their you
can imagine when the hungarians
converted
then they tried to they looked at the
they tried to unite themselves with the
biblical story of the christian story
right and then in their characteristics
they're like oh we're
we're nomads we're hunters we we live
you know this is how
our ancestors lived and therefore
connecting it to nimrod who was this
giant also because the hungarians are
are kind of are
kind of ogre like you know like even in
their own the way that they
that's why the ogres are are actually
hungarians you know
like i think some people think that the
word ogre comes from
from like at same root as hungarian oh
interesting
yeah exactly and so and so and so this
idea that they have
giant ancestors and that they were these
hunters and everything
um and so this is not even like people
saying it about them
right which is which because there's a
negative aspect to that like being a
descendant of nimrod is not like
necessarily all positive um but it's
like recognizing yourself and
your place in the story and then
understanding that that aspect can also
be converted and participate in the
you know in the universal salvation
yes um so yeah you have to connect
yourself back to noah
um this is even sort of there uh in in
uh
even in scandinavian folklore mythology
you know as
as those people christianized they look
back they look back at their ancestors
and one of the things that they try to
figure out was
where do we fit in and actually this
sort of thing has been going on ever
since the gospel according to saint luke
when luke writes his gospel so
there's the genealogy in matthew's
gospel which goes back to
goes back to abraham right
the genealogy in luke's gospel goes all
the way back to adam
and the point of this is that christ has
come
not as the savior just of the jewish
people
but as the as the universal savior right
so that there's a place you can go
you can trace your lineage back right
this is what luke is basically
encouraging his
gentile his his primary you know
primarily hellenic
readers to do is to figure out
where their story joins the line of atom
which you know theoretic that should be
everyone right so figure out where their
story joins the line of adam
because christ is the new adam so he's
going to actually assume or sort of
recapitulate
all of that stuff back into himself and
that's really
that's really where this begins in the
christian story
um and then of course it goes on uh to
to manifest itself in some really
dramatic ways with
uh one of my favorite historical figures
uh
which who we'll talk about in a minute
so
yeah um i thought it would be
go ahead well uh i mean i want to get to
uh basically
again so we grew up in the same kind of
subculture right so
so i don't know if people blamed
everything on constantine oh yeah so
we're moving towards constantine that's
right yeah
we're moving towards constantine yeah
but before we get to content we need yes
yes okay two sources the two sources are
really
noah yes and then troy and so tell us
more about
why is it that everybody's connecting
themselves to troy and even just tell us
how they are because it's pretty amazing
so let me talk about
the scandinavian peoples because this
will get both noah and troy in there
right so the scandinavian peoples have
this culture hero
um uh he's called shield
uh shield or um uh sheave
or sometimes like those are you know
some sources those are two different
people and then in like the beowulf poem
they're combined into one's
shield shaving which is basically shield
son of sheaf you know so it's the same
same character right so the the idea is
that uh
and and what the these christian monks
you know writing in the frozen
north actually it wasn't that frozen
there was a there was a warming period
so they were growing grapevines in
england at that time but
anyway these these uh these christian
monks writing in the
northern europe uh would actually tie
this time back and say you know
sheave or uh was was a son of noah who
was actually conceived and born on the
ark
uh there's actually a bunch of really
wild medieval legends
about a a a fourth son of noah who was
born on the ark
and actually there's there's there's
some in here uh so please buy this book
people this is a super cool book
there's some in here and sometimes like
it's a pretty monstrous thing
yeah um but actually that monstrousness
right that's part of that's part of the
story of the scandinavian peoples
especially as they first interact with
the roman world
so they sort of tied themselves back to
noah via this
the sort of fourth son who was maybe
born on the ark and then others you say
it was through the the line of japheth
who actually if you look at the
if you look at those div the the
divisions so a lot of people tried to
take
the the t what's called the table of
nations in genesis right so these 70
nations
that descend from noah's three sons who
are divided up after the tower of babel
and what they would do is they would try
to map those onto the nations that live
in the world today
and the crazy thing is that they mostly
get it right yeah um they get it more
right than they get it wrong
uh because what they basically end up
doing is mapping the three sons of
of of noah to the three major
linguistic groups of the ancient world
um it's
it's almost perfect actually so what
what you end up getting is
most of the people who they believe to
be descended from japheth
are speakers of indo-european languages
um
so it's it's from a philological
standpoint it's actually pretty
interesting
um and so so they see themselves as
maybe
born out of this monstrous fourth child
may be born out of this monstrous fourth
child who is born on the ark so he's
i mean you can think about the symbolism
of like he's not born on solid ground
right you know um he's born in between
worlds like he's
born in between figures right yeah and
even in even in beowulf
he's a liminal figure because he shows
up he just washes a short
during this interregnum period that the
danes have so the previous king
was bad and he's gone and they don't
have a king now and so they've lost
their culture they've lost technology
right and then she comes to them and uh
brings about this renewal
of the danish people and kind of founds
this mythical danish court which is
basically the danish equivalent the
scandinavian equivalent of the arthurian
story
so so he's this he's this and actually
arthur's got that same
sort of half monstrous uh element in
history
so does alexander alexander has that too
and the legend at least because he's the
son of a
of an egyptian priest posing as an
egyptian god
yeah he's like he's a bastard figure a
lot of these
a lot of these founders because they're
intermediary like they bridge two world
they
you know they're represented
mythologically as half human half snake
sometimes
they have different in you know in every
culture you always have
the the first king of all often is a
giant or a monster or some kind of a
hybrid figure because he's in kind of in
between worlds really
yeah so then the other part of this is
is troy
so troy is
i would say a full half of the master
story
of medieval civilization east and west
right um and the story of troy i mean
it's deeply important
uh it's it's one of the stories that if
you don't if you haven't read homer
and then then you you kind of i mean
it's hard to even know where to begin
and the fun thing is that actually a lot
of people
in the middle ages hadn't read homer but
they you know especially in the west
they didn't have homer until pretty late
but they had virgil yeah yeah they they
had the indeed so
in the aeneid what we see happening is
is the uh the origin story of the roman
people and specifically of the julian
family
right where julius caesar comes from and
and and literally every caesar after him
because even if you're not
born into the julian family to become
caesar you have to be adopted by the
previous caesar
um you know obviously the racoos and
things like that but that was the
normative way that things happened
so you could say every every caesar was
in in a sense part of the family of
julius caesar
right caesar's a family name before it's
a like a title
yeah so uh so and this was this is not a
news story that that
virgil is writing down um this is
already the self
understanding of the julian family and
some of the other major families of rome
was that they were descended from the
mythical
basically the exiles the people who lost
the trojan war they're the descendants
of the losers
right but the trojan war is not a
how do i say this it's not a if you read
homer there's no right side
yeah yeah it's a truly epic story in the
sense that it shows
all the the sides and you can you can
actually see the story from the
different sides
yeah it's it's it's a deeply complex
work it's a deeply complex work
and so uh and so the so they
even though they were the losing side
they were still seen as as
belonging to this older more beautiful
world
yeah and so to tie back to that is a way
of tying back to
the uh you know you could cynically say
it's a form of political legitimacy but
it's more than that it's
it's they're already trying to tie
themselves back into the older story
of their culture right and so um what
you have happening by the middle ages is
that almost every culture
um and i'll give father andrew a little
shout out here because he
he recently discovered that actually the
lithuanians and and uh
uh father andrew's been been sort of
recently reconnecting with his
lithuanian heritage
the lithuanians also have this story
that that their civilization was founded
by
refugees from troy um so what you have
by this time of the middle ages
is every major culture um
has somewhere in their story somewhere
in their founding story
this idea that they that they go back to
troy they'll have
you know um and and usually they'll not
always but usually this this will be
somehow tied into the
into aeneas family um because then what
that does is it connects you with both
the old
world and by the old world i mean like
the really old like the hellenic persian
world
but then it also connects you to rome
yeah and all of the things that rome
brings with it
you know there's something about the
india too that people need to understand
is that the aeneid was seen in many
medieval strains as have being somewhat
prophetic because
the prophecies about let's say the the
pronouncement that
that uh virgil makes about uh augustus
caesar
were interpreted by the the medieval
scholars as
ultimately talking about christ it's
like almost as if
virgil didn't know but the things he was
saying were really ultimately
uh referring to to christ you know
because because augustus was
seen as this kind of son of god figure
it's like the
then the the medieval people said the
real son of god that he was talking
about
without even knowing was was christ and
the interesting thing is it's
not even so much augustus as it is
augustus's son
who uh who dies in in childhood
right so so the prophecy uh this is book
six of the indeed
it's never realized in the roman story
until christ
yeah yeah yeah yeah um so it's it's this
really powerful thing and it was so
powerful
that many people in the middle ages
uh believed that you know
maybe virgil was a secret christian and
they sort of rejected that idea but
but they still wanted virgil to be uh
to be part of the christian story and of
course dante does this in a really
beautiful way
yeah but even much later on uh charles
williams
has this uh who's he's one of the
inklings and he's my least favorite
inkling because he's into some
not great stuff a lot of the times but
he does have this
he does have this uh he's really into
the occult
and and and kind of went went down some
bad roads by the end of his life but
um but he does have this one poem in his
uh he has a a
cycle of arthurian poetry called
taliesin through logos and in that he
actually has this
this idea that the the welsh bard
taliesin
who is a christian um
somehow by participation sort of like
goes into hell or back in time it's a
little ambiguous
and actually like is able to save virgil
as he's as he's falling into the abyss
right so there's this so so it's
people thought and and not just in that
uh not just in
in in uh in the init but some of
virgil's other poetry
they saw all of these you know sort of
foreshadowings of christ yeah
and i wanted to like take a little pause
as we before we go further
to help people understand why this
matters and what is going on
because we a lot of people might have
have known a little bit about this or
heard it in their different history
classes but it's usually presented
as as a as a kind of cheap trick as
a either as a way uh you know
from a protestant point of view as uh as
the syncretism you know and as this kind
of return to idolatry
and then from the kind of modern scholar
point of view as a
as a cheap trick that doesn't count that
you don't that you should
ignore and and that you should just look
at the at the either the more pagan
uh source versions of those stories um
like a good example will be in the etas
where
even though in the eddas is specifically
told from a christian point of view
the scholars today will say just ignore
that ignore that yeah just look at just
just go beyond that and what's really
important is that this is talking about
the ancient gods
but the process of trying to integrate
the past
into the new story is something which
has so much power
and so much meaning and is something
that christ
can also do which is just as christ
baptized
romans just as christ baptized rome
into into the church he can do the same
for all the ancient stories as well
can do the same for it doesn't mean that
everything gets in
it doesn't right some things get in some
things don't but there is this process
by which it has to narratively be
connected
so it's not just that we continue to
think that these stories exist
independently but we give them a
christian meaning they actually get
connected to the christian story
in the story itself so it really sort of
all hinges on how real you believe the
incarnation is
like how much of how much of humanity
did christ actually assume in himself
was it all of it does it go all the way
back to adam
well if if if it does then then all of
this
like anything that's good in any of this
stuff like it's sort of like
it's uh it's a it's you know it's the
deep magic
that it works in both directions you
know and so if you
if you believe i mean i've got this i i
think i said the sun the areopagus
podcast but i've got this
this this this theory that um
uh you you'll know a society is like
really christianized when it has a
specific icon of the mother of god
that's specific
to that culture you know like the poles
have the black madonna
and the the russians have the theotokos
vladimir and so on but
the reason for that is because she's so
deeply connected with the incarnation
um and so the more fully
christ becomes incarnate in that culture
right and obviously he became
from a historical perspective incarnate
in one particular place and time
but it's that particularity that the
that the universality we could say the
catholicity of the faith actually
depends on yeah
it becomes like a fulcrum like an access
around everything else
sort of a slowly sort of like a cross
shape i don't know
i don't know i don't know where we get
that idea i don't know
all right so now so i think that that
that we kind of got them
so the idea is that when we say that
everybody comes from troy so
like that we'll go through fast so
people can get a sense like
the germans the uh the scandinavians end
up seeing
the gods as being a rescue rescue from
troy
yeah so in snorri's stories etta uh
uh which is basically this it's actually
a manual for poets that he writes
it's not it's not intended to be like
here's systematic theology for norse
pagans that's yeah
which is how people use it which is
crazy it's not insane
uh but um but he actually begins it with
a story called gill forgetting which is
this
uh well what scholar city would call a
eu hemorrhage which is a nice way of
saying
oh these pagan gods were actually human
beings a long time ago and then people
started worshiping them
and by the way if you think that story
is is
uh let's say in conflict with the idea
that the gods of the nations are demons
you're not
understanding the story because those
things are not opposed
uh but any but that's a different story
for another time so
uh but in guilford beginning what we see
is is we get the
the real story right the real story of
the of the old norse gods
and the story of the norse gods and by
the way the the aesir the
the what we normally think of we think
of the norse gods odin and thor and all
those guys
right they're not scandinavian
originally they're not we know that
they're not
we know that those gods were imported
from somewhere else
and they took over and so that story is
explained as saying these were trojan
kings
and you know people from from trojan
lands the lands around troy
who after they were defeated by the
greeks they migrated north
and they took over
so okay yeah so that doesn't contradict
at all the idea that
the principalities would that all of
this would be happening at different
levels
at the same time right that all of this
is going on it's going on at the same
time
um so it's mostly to help people
understand that the that even the
neopagans like all of your new pagans
that are watching
like the ones the people who wrote hello
there the people who wrote those stories
were trying to connect this to the
universal story even though
you'd think that that that there's no
relationship between
scandinavians and the romans there was
this desire
to to join together and to have this
universal story
um so can we maybe in the time that's
left to us can we do my favorite one
let's go because this is this is the key
it's like the relationship between
king arthur and byzantium like that's
how deep this connection is
yeah so um let me let me talk and we
won't actually get into arthur today but
we'll no no no but
like it's still it's the source of all
that yeah so we'll set up a teaser and
then
we'll get into that so this is all from
uh this is all from the
the history of the kings of britain by
uh jeffrey of monmouth
and which is discounted by scholars
completely completely right
yeah completely discounted by scholars
right so uh
the way that it starts out is that the
island of britain and this is for all my
lord of spirits friends out there
okay so the island of britain is
believed was believed uh to have been
inhabited by
a giant clan uh the giant clan of albion
or so albie is an ancient name for the
island of britain
so alby and his sons were descended from
essentially this greek princess now keep
in mind that she's greek so she's from
as
at least in relation to britain she's
from the east
this greek princess who um she's
betrayed by her sisters who want to kill
their husbands
so that they can rule over their
kingdoms without being subservient
to men that's going to be important
later when we talk about arthur
and so the princes in question didn't
want to comply with the plot so she and
her her ladies uh they get set adrift
and they land on the island of britain
and there are no men
there for them to marry and so they end
up interbreeding with
evil spirits incubi right and they beget
a race of giants now of course if you're
listening been listening to the lord of
spirits podcast you will know
that this is how you get giants and i
just want to point out that this
version of the story survives all the
way into a 14th century
text so it's not like the idea
not you know that like the nephilim
ritual or the idea of where giants come
from it was never totally lost
especially out here
on what we could call like sort of the
edges of roman civilization
where contact with paganism were
contacts with paganism were sort of
ongoing so these giants
albion and his sons they rule over the
island of britain
until the coming of the trojan exile
brutus and brutus is kind of depending
on the version of the story he's either
the grandson or the great grandson of
aeneas
and therefore he's related to the roman
royal family he's part of the roman
story
so brutus has a journey uh which
actually kind of recapitulates the
journey of odysseus and aeneas he has a
stopover in africa he's a bunch of
battles he has an encounter with the
sirens
he actually founds the city of uh
forgive me if i say this wrong
tours in france um and uh
and he passes by a bunch of other
legendary locations until he eventually
reaches the island of albion which is
totally unpeopled except for the
remainders of this giant clan
and uh basically the last uh the the the
ruler of the giants there's only about
20 giants left but the ruler of them is
a giant
known as gog magog as in gog and magog
right and uh gog magog attacks brutus's
camp and he's eventually the giants are
defeated
and gog magog is killed in a wrestling
match with uh one of brutus's men
quirinius who goes on to found the
kingdom of cornwall
which is actually also a really
important uh element in the arthurian
story
and i'll just again point out there uh
put this out there that the way that
quirinius kills gog magog is that he
heaves him up onto his shoulders
and throws him off a cliff and into the
sea
so gog and magog
are slash the giant the nephilim
whatever you want to call them
they're they're removed from the kingdom
by being banished to the abyss which is
actually the same way that
christ gets rid of you know the demons
put some sends them into the pigs
like we read that we read the gospel
like three times a year liturgically in
the orthodox church like it's like a
disproportionately read story but the
reason is because it's
it's this powerful story of of the
defeat of
the defeat of these demonic powers of
these of these these giants
yeah we need to remind people that in
the the alexander legend
gog and magog are uh are not a
giant per se but they're they're like a
race of monsters a race of kind of
cannibalistic
insane uh creatures and they get shut
out of civilization by
being you know there's these these gates
that are that are built and they get
thrown
behind those gates and they're there
they're supposed to stay there until the
end of the world
when they right let loose and yeah onto
the world yeah yes
so with the giants
banished brutus establishes the kingdom
of britain right
and so the legendary history that
jeffrey of monmouth lays out
traces this line of trojan british
rulers
um in all of the ways and times that it
intersects with the roman empire because
we'll remember that
you know julius caesar invaded uh
the island of britain said to claudius
uh claudius nero
um so uh it uh
so we see these trojans
inter-intersecting and fighting with the
roman empire who we must remember
the romans are also trojans yeah so it's
a
it's a very complicated narrative that
he lays out it's multiple chapters
and i won't try to summarize it here but
essentially to say it's
it's this conflicting is this
complicated narrative of conflicting
principalities
and ultimately the way that the
principle that the conflict is resolved
is by a marriage alliance between a
british king
and a roman princess and this line
ultimately produces among other people
the roman emperor constantine the great
and that's something that people
always have to remember that constantine
comes from britain like this is not this
is not like now we're not in
not in the legendary history anymore
this is like everybody knows constantine
comes from britain this is really
this is part of how this is part of the
universal story of christianity here
yeah so even if he wasn't born in
britain st constantine
is is indeed he's very british according
to just your boring old history books
right he's first acclaimed emperor by
the roman legions in in
brick yeah and i just have to point out
here though that his mother
helen uh she was claimed to be
uh depending on this the medieval source
either a native of
anatolia which is where troy was
or uh and she was and and therefore and
a greek
or uh britain in antiquity in the middle
ages and it should be clear enough by
now if you've been paying
attention that these two origins origins
for st
helen they're not mutually exclusive
they're actually
polyvalent to say that she's from troy
and by the way her name is helen okay
yeah
so like you can't make this stuff up
like to say that she's
she's uh a greek from the area of troy
which helen helen you know was was greek
and then taken detroit right so to say
that she's a greek from the area of troy
or to say that she's uh part of this you
know part of this
trojan remnant in the british isles
that's that's
those things are really close and so you
know they're they're polyvalent you know
they're not totally the same but they
they have overlapping senses of meaning
and so then what we see
is that in the same way uh that that she
you know helen is
instead of a divider like helen of troy
was or helen
sparta um instead of being a divider
um helen uh st helen is she's a uniter
right
and so what she's able to do is she's
able to
uh and she's a very important feminine
figure in christianity especially in
oh yeah in in the orthodox church right
very
she heals the helen yeah like she's
actually she exactly
exactly like and and and what she does
is and of course then like saint olga
right in baptism
her baptismal name was helen right so
it's
it's almost like it's almost like if
you're gonna have a woman
to fill this role she has to be named
helen just
just like just like so you so maybe the
way to think about it is this you know
we have this idea of the the virgin mary
is the new eve
right but within christianity there's
also the idea of saint helen
and and then saint olga as the new helen
of trump yeah
and you can say and it's it's it's a
beautiful parallel right
because completely and does like you
could say the trojan war is like the
first hard divide between sort of east
and west
right and then what helen what st helen
does is she actually heals that those
things she brings them together
so she's either an eastern person or
she's a trojan but either way
she's the one who is able to communicate
christianity to her son
and then what constantine does i mean
this is
crazy if you think about this so
constantine goes to found his famous
city constantinople within just a few
miles of the ruins
of troy where does he found his city
it's amazing yeah within within a few
miles
of the of the ruins of the city of troy
so you've got constantinople which is
also called
new rome and if you read
jeffrey of monmouth he'll tell you that
the original name of london in the in
the universal history
the original name of london is new troy
so you've got
you've got movement from from east to
west
troy to new troy and then movement from
west to east
rome which is troy to new rome
which is at the location of old troy so
there's this crash
and of course obviously the story of the
the the
the cross is obviously super important
to constantine's story
yeah but it's so it's so important that
it's actually
embedded in the basic shape of his
narrative
there's this x-shaped cross-shaped
movement
in the development of roman history and
western civilization you have exiles
from troy
move west to found a new troy which is
either alba longa
you know which eventually becomes rome
or it's london new troy
uh either way that's the same story and
then you have a king from new troy
constantine is a roman emperor but he's
also from britain
uh moving east to the ruins of old troy
to found
the new rome which is constantinople
which becomes
the first christian city there are no
pagan temples in constantinople
right and but in doing that he takes
this
this thing that started back with
alexander
right this this this this merging
together of the hellenic and the hebrew
narratives
uh which was not always it didn't always
go smoothly there's this whole thing
called the maccabees you know if you
read about that
but it didn't always go smoothly but but
then what constantine does
but it didn't go smoothly because christ
had not yet entered the picture
you know he was hidden you know and
hidden down in sort of the
the roots of history but he hadn't yet
emerged right the
the stump i mean i mean this is
literally the language of the bible
the stump of jesse had been cut down and
it had not yet sprung up again
yeah and so when it springs up
that creates the the potential right
that creates the potential for
the hellenic and the judaic stories or
the roma
you know roman greco-roman ninja and the
and the jewish stories
to actually merge um and so
when the people that we grew up around
or you know people out there on the
internet say oh
constantine introduced all this paganism
into the church right they're not
right but they're also right in a way
that they don't realize they're right
they don't understand yeah they just
they just don't understand that actually
constantine's merging of these things
was first of all it's the only way it
could have gone right it's the
fulfillment
of you know it's the cross
yeah right um and also the few things to
understand is that britain
what's suggested in the story of britain
and even the reality of written is that
it was considered the end of the world
consider the edge of the world which is
why the romans were constantly trying to
build walls out there to stop these
insane
like crazy naked barbarians from like
flooding into the into the world
so just like alexander built a wall you
know
at the caspian sea then the emperors
built there were two walls the
there were two imaginal lines that that
that the uh that the the hadrian's wall
and uh what's the name of the other wall
and to end antonine wall so there's
there are two walls that the romans
built
out there in britain to like stop these
these insane barbarians from propping in
so
it was understood as the western edge of
civilization
and troy was the beginning of this whole
story right
so constantine joins them together
right through rome itself and so it's
like you have the
the middle the edge and the other edge
like the beginning this middle part and
then the other edge
all kind of brought together into one
into one story so
which is going that goes back to and by
the way i know you're a francophone
because you said
maginot lion which is like that it would
never occur
to it to to an anglo
well we would just we would just say
like a wall like okay you know like we
don't go to the maginot line as oh yeah
that
that's a that's a good way to explain
this but anyway i i just love that
that's that's that's so and then
constantine so constantine's actual like
even the history of constantine which is
still preserved
by modern historian right still has so
much mythical in it
yeah and so the fact that constantine
wins his battle on a bridge
it's all about that right it's all about
this and and
if you read the descriptions of the the
the battle of melvian bridge you get the
sense that he's like
he's like the new moses he's he's
crossing the red sea he's crossing the
flood
all this imagery of like a transition
between two worlds
uh as this kind of and also as kind of
bringing together
these opposites like this this new world
that will join
all of this together is there like right
in his own story
and that's the same we a few minutes ago
we were talking about the joining of
history and apocalypse right the
beginning of a thing and the end of the
thing
right that's that's what constantine is
doing
right he's joining the the beginning and
the end and what has he joined them with
he joins them with the cross
yeah and so i think we're getting
fixed everything i just have to say that
on the internet so it's recorded
keep saying the constantine constantine
fixed everything
well they just say christ fixed
everything yes and then
constantine constantine participated in
like the
the fruits of that and manifested like
the hidden fruits that that were there
from the from the cross
um and so i think so we'll stop there
but
just to get it give people a hint of
where this goes is that
you now you have to remember that arthur
is not the idea that author arthur is
like this this like
celtic pagan figure is absolute nonsense
like arthur is the descendant of these
people he's a descendant of these
trojans that are that are
in in britain and so all of this is
going to help you understand
how this universal story then continues
and how britain itself plays such an
important part because of this because
of how it is the edge of the world
because of how
it was the place out of which
constantine came to bridge everything
together
um and how this is really really is a
mythical story
laying itself out um and so i hope you
guys are
like i i struggle to think you could be
as excited about
than as us as about this story but what
we hope
is we want to start to bring this into
the four of your consciousness
uh so that you can see that these
connections are not arbitrary
and that we even though we don't have to
give up completely
a more critical historical approach we
don't have to give that up but
but we need to be able to see these
connections as extremely meaningful and
based on meaning
and on identities of these people and
how they saw themselves
right and so sometimes it's not
necessarily even positive like the fact
that
the example that i gave with the
hungarians or that or the scandinavians
who saw themselves
as a monstrous son of noah it's not just
about boasting and about
making your your people to be the best
and there it is really is about a
piercing into the mystery of the
light and dark sides of your own people
and seeing how
this all connects together into this
this giant puzzle so
yeah so i'm hoping you guys are excited
about this because i
i really want us to kind of move on to
both east and west we'll talk about
arthur we'll talk about
the the the byzantine prophecies and the
byzantine notion of the
the uh the coming emperor like the
hidden and coming emperor that is
similar to arthur
and we got to talk about ethiopia as
well you know definitely we need to
definitely need to talk about ethiopia
yeah very important
all right everybody so thank you for
your time i hope you
you enjoyed this little trip that we
brought you on go for it oh yeah let's
talk about
yeah let me just talk about a couple of
of cool projects which you go for this
sort of thing
you would want to check out so as i
mentioned earlier i'm the co-host of the
amateur podcast on ancient faith radio
if you just want to come hear me talk
about tolkien which is actually what i
do to sound sane to people i know that's
crazy
the stuff i'm talking about today like
this is the the stuff i get really
excited about but like i have to
normally keep a lid on it but uh but uh
so i talk about tolkien
um and we have this book out now uh it's
it's kind of like a who's who of people
who've been on the edmonton podcast
um yep it's called amid weeping there is
joy orthodox perspectives on tolkien's
fantastic realm
and it is officially endorsed by me even
so if you look at the back of the book
it's got an official endorsement
on the back endorsed by jonathan pageau
and
and um also uh great forward by father
under stephen damick there's an essay in
here
by me on rude screens and ritual space
in in tolkien and the pearl poem which
is amazing by the way
you people would i think it's very good
it's really was written for all the
people
listening to my podcast it really was
when i read it it's like i was like this
is for uh this is for us
but there's also an article about
nicholas kotar
that people around here know and it is i
think like the first fruits of
getting a sense not the first truth but
one of the first fruits of giving a
sense of how
we're moving towards something which is
really going to resemble like
an intellectual movement a culture
movement a social movement
uh all these people who see the
possibility of re-enchantment
and uh and richard has really been
playing a great role in that
so tell us a few of the other things
you're involved in um
uh may 7th and 8th um we are
father andrew steven damack and i will
be hosting an online
conference on tolkien and orthodox
christianity it's going to be called
dachshund online that will be giants
so please show up to that um it's only
30 bucks you can sign up for it at
store.ancientfaith.com forward slash
docsimoot d-o-x-a-m-o-o-t
um and there's still plenty of spots
open so please join us for that
there's a couple of things you really
don't want to miss one is uh
is father andrew talking about
enchanting orcs and about the idea of
sort of like demonic incarnation and the
way that tolkien plays with that
in his mythology the other though is
that i'm going to be giving a talk
on the recovery of actually what for a
few years
i've been calling in in talk in in talks
i've given in articles
what i've been calling the sacramental
imagination what father andrew's been
referring to is re-enchantment and
really what is basically jonathan's
whole deal here on the symbolic world
and uh basically it's going to be my
premise to give a little teaser
that uh it's a real problem that it's
easier to talk about the inklings than
it is to write good stories
and saying that as somebody who's like
contributed more than my fair share of
ink and air time to talking about the
inklings right
we need good storytellers you know
christian storytellers
who understand the stuff deep in their
bones
and the fact that we don't have very
many people doing that with a couple of
exceptions
uh the fact that we don't have very many
people doing that right now tells me
that there's something that the inklings
had that we've lost
so i'm gonna try to take a stab at
answering that question but then that's
also gonna kick off
a new book so the talk that i'm giving
is called
fighting the golden key which is a nice
little george mcdonald reference that
some of our
symbolic world readers will understand
it's called finding the golden key
recovering this the sacramental
imagination and next year
in the fall of 2022 there's going to be
a book of the same title coming out
that's going to be a collection of
essays
edited and curated by myself um i'm
going to be
soliciting uh essays from several
symbolic world people i've already
i've already talked to jonathan about
yes he's gotta he's gotta submit
something
um but i also actually i'm gonna be
opening it up to the community
so if you're if you're interested in
this sort of thing
and you'd like to contribute an essay um
there will be
uh we'll have a website up by the time
of doc submits so the so that you can go
there and actually uh submit
uh like a a summary of of what you'd
like to pitch
so that's going to be published by the
eighth day institute and we're actually
going to have a big book launch party
for it
in wichita kansas which is the actual
center of the world
you thought it was jerusalem it's
actually wichita
um because here's because wichita has
the greatest bookstore in the universe
um but we're gonna uh so we're gonna be
launching it there next fall
um and uh maybe you know we'll see what
travel conditions are like this
you know fall of 2022 but maybe we can
get some of these people
all together in one place which would be
i mean amazing convergence
yeah that would be great like to have an
actual meeting together with people
yeah yeah so please sign up and come to
dachshund
uh you won't regret it even if you're
not orthodox or you're like i don't know
about all this tolkien stuff come anyway
because
there will be something for you that's
great so it really i think it's
it's just exciting time it's a it's a
dark time but it's also an exciting time
because we
we are starting to kind of see who who
it is that's working together towards
this re-enchantment and who
who is trying to plant the seeds for
this for this kind of these future
fruits so
so richard thanks for all the work you
do on symbolic world
all the things you do which you also
have a job which i can't imagine that
you do all these things
so and you also have four kids which is
astounding so all of that thank you for
for
putting your heart into this and we'll
definitely talk very soon
thanks jonathan thanks for having me oh
it's great